Republicans are expected to vote next
week on whether to begin debating a
health care bill now right now it's not
clear what will be in that bill Senate
Majority Whip John Cornyn was asked
yesterday if Republicans would know
beforehand what they'd be voting on he
said quote that's a luxury we don't have
shannon petty piece is Bloomberg's White
House correspondent Shannon good morning
so why don't they know what Bill they're
gonna be voting on because Republicans
haven't been able to come together on
any consensus about what they would like
to do there's a couple options out there
now one would be flat-out repeal
Obamacare with a delay for two years to
give them a couple years to come up with
some sort of replacement there is a bill
right now with a replacement option as
of last night that replacement option
still didn't have enough votes there's
some amendments that could be added on
to that replacement option that could
maybe help bring some people on board
but there's still no pathway to 50 votes
right now yet they're still planning to
have a vote next week and the president
is still pushing them to have a vote
next week we're likely without John
McCain without John McCain and they can
lose no more than two votes so this is a
fine needle that they have to thread
here in order to get this bill passed we
already know Susan Collins is a pretty
hard no Rand Paul is a pretty hard no
and then John McCain unless there is
some change at the last minute where
he's able to get back and make a vote
and either way these bills whichever
they choose to put a votes down for are
not popular
we have CBO report suggesting that 15
million people according to the
Republican plan at least will lose
insurance by next year isn't that
fundamentally the problem that these are
not popular bills and these Republican
senators know that they're not popular
with the public they're not popular with
their base they're not popular with
members of Congress yes exactly
the house was able to get this passed
and a lot of members have to hold their
nose there and just pass this because
they hope the Senate would do something
to fix it well here we are at the Senate
there's not many more safety checks or
guardrails ahead whatever you vote for
is likely going to become law and that's
the fate that they're facing right now
that they don't like but what is
interesting with the president is he
isn't
that making a popular making a deal he
wants a deal on this right and he was
involved in the house talks he was there
was a lot of reports that he was sort of
sending the sidelines in the Senate
discussions to begin with now he's
involved again telling them potentially
don't take your break how much is that
that nudging and elbowing with Dean
Heller and others affecting what's going
on right now I was in part of this
luncheon they had earlier this week with
the president and members of the Senate
it was the first time I really saw him
make a sales pitch for this bill not
just saying this is a good bill this is
a good start and then secretly calling
it mean when everybody left the room he
was actually making a sales pitch
talking about the taxes it would remove
talking about the changes to Medicaid
the entitlement reform that it would do
he really seemed engaged but too little
too late may be the case because as
you're pointing out the messaging and
the story about this bill is already out
there 22 million people would lose
coverage according to the CBO score they
have are struggling to get the message
under control and on their turf and I
don't think in the next week or two
weeks they're gonna be able to convince
enough people that this is a popular
bill to move forward on it President
Trump promised during the campaign no
cuts to Medicaid it doesn't just about
every Republican plan include cuts to
Medicaid it does that's the one thing
the Republicans seem to have some sort
of consensus on whether or not now how
much do you cut medicine on Capitol Hill
on the hill yeah how much do you cut
Medicaid how do you cut it but there's a
view that Medicaid is an entitlement
that we need to reform it the program's
gotten too big we need to put it on a
major diet and reel it back in but if
you do that however you shake it certain
millions of people are going to lose
coverage because one in five Americans
are on Medicaid right now two-thirds of
people in nursing homes are on Medicaid
right now you cut that program you're
going to be affecting some of those
people a lot of pressure on Mitch
McConnell the question is is the
president helping or hurting him thank
you so much for joining a Shannon petty
piece Sunday on Face the Nation John
Dickerson will speak with two Republican
senators Susan Collins and Maine's John
Barrasso of Wyoming Susan Collins of
course of Maine and john of wyoming that
sunday here on CBS